vimos en el último vídeo que las bases
[ __ ] normales funcionan muy bien para
sistemas de coordenadas entonces vimos
justamente sobre bases [ __ ] normales las
bases [ __ ] normales sirven muy bien para
los sistemas de coordenadas y que de
hecho sirven muy bien en el sentido de
que es fácil calcular fácil de calcular
las coordenadas
las coordenadas muy bien en eso hicimos
en el último vídeo ahora veamos si hay
otras razones por la cual es útil tener
bases [ __ ] normales y como siempre pues
vamos a tener que empezar con b que sea
un un sub espacio un sub espacio de
nuestro espacio general rn ok entonces
tomamos un sub espacio de rn y vamos a
suponer que conocemos una base de este
sub espacio digamos que el conjunto de
el conjunto b formado por los vectores
digamos b1 b2 y así sucesivamente hasta
beca forman una base
se portó normal aquí es lo importante ya
no es cualquier base es una base [ __ ]
normal de nuestro sub espacio ve ok y
que no es otra cosa más que una forma
elegante para decirle que este conjunto
de vectores son ortogonales entre sí y
que además la norma de cada uno de ellos
es uno muy bien entonces tenemos esta
base [ __ ] normal que otra cosa sabemos
si nos tomamos un vector x cualquiera
en rn sabemos que podemos descomponerlo
en una suma verdad y eso es
descomponerlo como vemos w demás w y lo
importante aquí es que el el vector b el
vector b se encuentra en nuestro sub
espacio y sabemos que w se encuentra en
él
en el complemento ortogonal de nuestro
sub espacio de hecho sabemos que a este
este changuito que tenemos aquí
la proyección la proyección sobre el sub
espacio be the x y w sería la proyección
de x sobre el sub espacio del
complemento ortogonal de be y en general
no es fácil calcular quién es la
proyección hay que multiplicar un buen
de matrices y eso lo vuelve bastante
engorroso pero pero de hecho de hecho
vamos a recordar cómo se hace
teníamos una matriz a y que la
construyamos de tal suerte que las
columnas de ésta eran los vectores que
formaban una base de nuestro sub espacio
muy bien entonces decíamos o más bien no
decíamos habíamos demostrado que la
proyección sobre el sub espacio del
vector x se calculaba como la
multiplicación de a por a transpuesta
por a todo esto a la menos uno por
transpuesta que multiplica al vector x
ok y esto esto de aquí calcular esta
multiplicación de matrices en general
era un terrible dolor de cabeza porque
son muchísimas operaciones que si lo
hacemos con papel y lápiz pues puede
resultar bastante complicado y bastante
engorroso pero que a lo mejor una
computadora podría hacerlo rápidamente
entonces vamos a seguir experimentando
con todas estas operaciones y veamos si
si si el hecho de tener bases orton
normales simplifica la forma de calcular
esta proyección a lo mejor ya no
tendremos que utilizar la multiplicación
de matrices pero quizás podríamos éste
encontrar una forma fácil de escribir
esto
entonces vamos a tomarnos ahora
vamos a tomarnos este x
vamos a tomarnos este vector x x y como
sabemos que nuestro vector b se
encuentra en el sub espacio se encuentra
en este sub espacio y este conjunto es
una base para ver entonces b lo podemos
escribir como una combinación lineal de
estos vectores b1 b2 hasta beca entonces
ve vamos a escribir primero b es que
digamos c 1 tecno ponerlo con otro color
es c 1 por b 1 más de 2 por b 2
todos estos hasta seca por beca esto
todo esto todo esto de aquí es nuestro
lector ve que también sabemos que es la
proyección la proyección sobre el sub
espacio ve de equis y nos falta sumarle
w aunque entonces más w aunque ya estés
ve aquí esta vez y w
aquí está w muy bien entonces sí sí sí
seguimos experimentando como en él como
en el vídeo anterior qué pasaría si
multiplicamos a x por alguno de estos
vectores de la base entonces que tenemos
por ejemplo si multiplicamos por el que
ustedes quieran ver punto x será igual a
b y por éste que sería c 1 por b y punto
de 1
c 2 b y punto b 2 y así sucesivamente
hasta que encontremos el vector de y
verdad y nos quedaría b y punto
más
nos seguimos todos los que faltan hasta
seca por d
y punto beca ok entonces hasta aquí
hemos hecho la multiplicación de todos
estos sólo nos faltaría multiplicar b y
punto el vector w
wv y bueno esto es bastante útil porque
muy parecido a lo que hicimos en el
vídeo anterior
tenemos que estos como como es una base
[ __ ] normal esto se hace cero verdad
porque tenemos tenemos dos elementos
distintos de la base que se multiplican
entonces nos da cero esto nos da cero
todos éstos nos dan cero excepto uno que
es cuando coincide en verdad y éste nos
da uno porque esto es la norma al
cuadrado que sabemos que es 1 entonces
aquí solo me restaría el c y ahora qué
pasa con b y punto w bueno notemos que w
se encuentra en el complemento ortogonal
de b y eso quiere decir que es ortogonal
a todos los vectores de mi psuv espacio
b en particular si yo tengo b y esteve y
vive en el sub espacio b entonces estos
dos son ortogonales y al hacer la
multiplicación del producto punto nos da
nuevamente 0 entonces tenemos un
resultado muy parecido a la anterior
por qué
si aquí este es el único que nos queda
si va a ser igual a punto equis y solo
para clarificar un poquito en el vídeo
anterior nos tomamos a equis un elemento
cualquiera pero del sub espacio b aquí
nos estamos tomando x cualquier elemento
de rn no importa el que sea ya no
necesariamente tiene que vivir solo en
el sub espacio b ok en este caso puede
vivir en cualquier lugar ahora entonces
sí sí ya tenemos que seguir es la
multiplicación con producto punto del
vector y de la base con el vector x
entonces podemos ya escribir muy bien o
ya podemos hallar la proyección del
vector x sobre el sub espacio b de una
forma más sencilla porque simplemente
era el vector b que se escribía como
esta combinación lineal de los vectores
de la base pero si ya sabemos quién es
cada uno de los coeficientes entonces
simplemente podríamos decir que la
proyección
el sub espacio del vector x es esta
combinación lineal donde se 1 pues será
de 1 punto x que multiplica al vector
déjenme hacerlo con otro color
no nos perdamos esto va a ser c1 c1
dijimos que es de 1 punto x
que multiplica el vector de uno más de
dos que es de 2 x
y que multiplica el vector de 2 y así
nos seguimos sumando todos los términos
hasta beca punto
x que multiplica el vector ve acá muy
bien entonces esta es una fórmula para
encontrar la proyección sobre el sub
espacio b del de cualquier vector x
siempre queremos una base orton normal
una base [ __ ] normal de nuestro sub
espacio b entonces si recordamos cuando
tenemos la proyección sobre sobre una
línea si recordamos cuando tenemos la
proyección sobre una línea de un vector
x donde aquí la línea pues sería el
espacio generado por todos los múltiplos
de un vector digamos unitario verdad
todos los múltiplos de un vector
unitario y vamos a suponer que es un
vector de norma 1 entonces si utilizamos
esta observación tenemos que la
proyección es x punto
que multiplica al vector y ok entonces
si nos damos cuenta entonces la
proyección sobre el sub espacio completo
no es otra cosa más que la suma de
muchísimas proyecciones sobre cada una
de las líneas sobre cada una de las
líneas que genera la base de nuestro sub
espacio de lo cual es algo muy muy muy
agradable de observar
entonces hagamos brevemente un repaso de
qué es lo que estamos haciendo tenemos
una base [ __ ] normal queremos ver para
qué demonios nos sirve y en general era
muy complicado calcularlo verdad
calcular la proyección de un vector
sobre un sub espacio b había que hacer
estas estos cálculos o estas operaciones
con matrices que se vuelven difíciles
pero utilizando la propiedad de que es
una base [ __ ] normal llegamos a una
expresión muy agradable de cómo escribir
la proyección [ __ ] normal de este vector
entonces
ahora lo que podemos preguntarnos es
bueno sabemos que la proyección de esta
proyección es una función es una
transformación lineal entonces habrá
algunos que queramos saber quién es la
matriz de transformación de éste desde
la proyección ok
quizás sea útil para algunas
aplicaciones que soy yo podría ser
entonces vamos a ver si el hecho de que
sean una base ortogonal nos ayuda con el
hecho de calcular la matriz de la
transformación entonces sabemos vamos a
notar lo que sabemos que la proyección
sobre un sub espacio del vector x es
esta matriz a que multiplica a
transpuesta por a a la menos uno por
atrás pues está y multiplica al vector x
donde sabemos también que la matriz a la
construimos como aquella matriz que
tiene como columnas a los vectores de la
base
muy bien
base del psuv espacio b y esta matriz si
queremos hacer a transpuesta por lo que
vamos a querer calcular es a transpuesta
por a entonces si tenemos a transpuesta
x a quien es pues bueno si tenemos si
queremos escribir a transpuesta todo lo
que son columnas pasan a ser renglones
entonces
lo que son columnas ahora son renglones
aquí tenemos el vector b 1 transpuesto
ahora visto como renglón el vector b 2
transpuesto visto como renglón y así
sucesivamente hasta el vector beck ha
transpuesto visto como renglón muy bien
que va a multiplicar a nuestra matriz a
que esa ya la ya la tenemos aquí
la matriz que tiene al vector b 1
todos como columnas verdad como columnas
así sucesivamente hasta el vector bk
entonces quién es esto vamos a ver quién
sería esto
esto si nos damos cuenta esta es una
matriz de la matriz a es una matriz de n
por acá entonces la matriz a transpuesta
es de acá por n éste es de n por acá y
por lo tanto nos queda una matriz de acá
por acá es decir es una matriz cuadrada
muy bien es una matriz cuadrada
me hago bien este
este cierre de la matriz ahí está
entonces nuestra primera coordenada está
dado por el producto punto del primer
renglón con la primera columna entonces
b 1 punto b 1 como es una base [ __ ]
normal es la longitud de b 1 al cuadrado
que es 1
muy bien de hecho vamos a ver que en la
diagonal vamos a tener puros unos porque
en la diagonal tenemos el producto punto
d
el renglón con la columna
correspondiente por ejemplo en el
segundo será de 2 este vector ve dos
punto el vector b 2 entonces es la norma
al cuadrado que es 1 entonces así nos
podemos dar cuenta de que en realidad
sobre la diagonal solo vamos a tener
unos ahora vamos a ver quién o quién qué
número ocupa este lugar entonces en ese
lugar simplemente se calcula como el
vector de 1 punto
la columna de 2 pero como son otra vez
ortogonales estos su producto punto es 0
muy bien qué pasa en el siguiente
y aquí lo que hemos hecho hasta ahorita
fue hacer este producto de este con este
otro si nosotros hacemos el producto
punto con el tercero b 1 punto b 3 que
es este renglón con esta columna nos va
a quedar 0 porque son ortogonales
entonces en general si hacemos el
producto de b 1 con todos los demás que
no son b 1 por ser ortogonales nos
quedan puros ceros si ahora partimos con
b 2 y hacemos el producto punto con b 1
con esta columna nos queda 0 ya hicimos
con b 2 y si lo hacemos con cualquier
otro vector nos van a dar ceros porque
son ortogonales entonces esta matriz se
puede rellenar de forma muy fácil verdad
esto se rellena con puros ceros
y se dejan puros 1 sobre la diagonal
entonces esta matriz tiene un nombre muy
especial y de hecho es una matriz de acá
por acá y no es otra cosa más que la
matriz identidad de cada década por acá
verdad entonces realmente calcular a
transpuesta por a si tenemos una base
[ __ ] normal si partimos de esta base
[ __ ] normal vamos a tener que a
transpuesta x a a transpuesta x a
va a ser igual a la matriz identidad de
acá por acá y entonces la inversa de a
transpuesta por a pues es la inversa de
la matriz identidad pero la inversa de
la matriz identidad es ella misma
entonces la proyección que nosotros
habíamos escrito como esta
multiplicación de matrices se simplifica
muchísimo porque ahora tenemos que la
proyección sobre el sub espacio b del
vector x es
no escribirlo
y es a por esta matriz a transpuesta a
la menos 1 que es la matriz identidad de
k por k que multiplica a transpuesta por
x pero bueno realmente poner esta matriz
es como haber hecho nada solo hace
cosquillas en esta parte y es se queda a
por a transpuesta por equis y que aún
hay que multiplicar matrices pero esto
es mucho más fácil verdad antes teníamos
que multiplicar cuatro matrices ahora ya
nada más tenemos que multiplicar dos
entonces realmente si queríamos
encontrar la matriz por la matriz
asociada a la transformación de la
proyección inicialmente es esta cosa muy
complicada de aquí pero utilizando una
base [ __ ] normal
y las propiedades que eso conlleva
llegamos a que sólo hay que multiplicar
dos matrices a por a transpuesta de
todas formas espero que esto te haya
dado más apreciación de lo que son las
bases orton normales y para que son
útiles